Today in history, on August 15th, in the
year 718, Constantinople hurled back the
greatest assault the forces of Islam had
yet mustered, and in so doing preserved
the survival of all of Western
civilization. The irony runs deep. The
siege had begun on this very date a year
earlier, August 15, 717, and it ended
exactly one year later, as if the city's
fate had been bound to that day. And
deeper still is the bitter fate that
Constantinople, once the shield of
Christendom, went on to suffer. The
story is worth retelling in full. So,
here we go. After several failed sieges,
in the year 715, the Umiad Caliphate
decided that enough was enough. This
time, it would vomit forth everything it
had in a single all-consuming effort to
bring down the ancient Christian
capital. Khalif Sullean summoned his
younger brother, Maslema, commanding him
to lead Islam's forces to Constantinople
and stay there until you conquer it or I
recall you. The young Amir accepted the
task as a sacred honor. He vowed that
quote, "I will enter this city knowing
that it is the capital of Christianity
and my only purpose in entering it is to
uphold Islam and humiliate unbelief." At
the head of 120,000 Muslim fighters,
according to the sources, Muslma crossed
into Christian territory. And as one
near contemporary chronicler records,
quote, "With both sword and fire, he put
an end to Asia Minor. On August 15th,
717, the Muslim host began its assault
on the city, which was under the command
of Emperor Leo III, formerly a general.
Just weeks earlier, General Leo, on
being deemed the ablest man to face the
crisis, had been consecrated as new
emperor in the Haga Sophia, then the
beating heart of Eastern Christendom,
though today a mosque. At any rate,
unable to breach Constantinople's
cyclopian walls, Maslema awaited the
arrival of 1,800 ships carrying an
additional 80,000 warriors to choke the
city into submission. It was then that
Leo acted. He ordered the massive harbor
chain, the city's ancient maritime gate
cast aside. As the Muslim fleets
hesitated, wondering whether to seize
the opportunity, the ministers of
destruction were at hand, writes
Theophanes, the chronicler. Leo had
unleashed the firebearing ships.
Theophanes describes this scene. Quote,
"Some of them, the Muslim ships were
cast up burning by the seaw walls.
Others sank to the bottom with their
crews, and still others were swept down
flaming. Greek fire, the Empire's
closely guarded weapon, turned the
waters into an inferno, as captured in
this 12th century illustration of the
naval battle in question.
Then came one of the crulest winters
that anyone could remember. Snow covered
the ground for 100 days. Muslims men
froze, starved, and prayed for supplies
that never came. Bulgars, warlike tribes
from the north, harried any Muslim
detachment that ventured out in search
of food. As Muslma soon learned, his
brother Khalif Sullean had died of
indigestion after gorging on two baskets
of eggs and figs, followed by gobs of
marrow and sugar. His successor, Khalif
Omar II, preoccupied with consolidating
his own rule, initially paid little
attention to the starving army encamped
before the Christian capital. When
spring finally arrived, reinforcements
began to trickle in, but frost, famine,
and disease had already decimated the
Muslim host. Theophanes records that,
quote, "Since the Arabs were extremely
hungry, they ate all their dead animals,
horses, asses, and camels. Some even say
they put dead men in their own dung in
pans, needed this, and ate it. A
plague-like disease descended on them,
and destroyed a countless throng.
Even so, Omar could not bring himself to
abandon the siege. To be the one to
capture that one remaining infidel
kingdom, which mocked Islam's advance,
was too great a temptation. A fresh
navy, 800 more ships, was fitted out in
Alexandria and Libya, and sailed to
blockade the Boserus. Having learned to
fear Greek fire, they kept their
distance. It all seemed up for
Constantinople at this point. But
salvation soon came and from a very
unexpected source. The crews manning the
Muslim fleets were not Arabs, but
Egyptian conscripts, and all of them
were Christian, that is cops. In the
dead of night, the sailors conspired,
seized the transport skiffs, and
defected to the city, hailing Leo as
their new sovereign. Theophanes writes
that quote the sea appeared to be
covered with timber as the cops sailed
to their co-religionists. The defection
stripped the Muslim fleet of crucial
manpower and handed Leo valuable
intelligence of the enemy's plans. Once
again, the chain was lifted, the fire
ships were loosed, and the
confrontation, or rather conflration,
decimated the Muslims. Leo went on to
press his advantage. He persuaded the
Bulgar tribes to strike the now
retreating Muslim land forces, killing
as many as 22,000 half-st starved and
exhausted men. At last, Khalif Omar
recalled Muslimma. On August 15th, in
the year 718, exactly one year after the
siege began, the Muslim host withdrew,
but its tribulations were far from over.
A violent storm wrecked many Muslim
ships in the Sea of Marmara, and a
volcanic eruption on Santorini rained
fiery ash on others. Of the 2,500 Muslim
ships that were retreating to Damascus
and Alexandria, only 10 reached their
destination. Of the 200,000 Muslims who
had marched or sailed to subdue the
Christian capital, only some 30,000
straggled back home. Contemporaries saw
the hand of divine providence in the
city's salvation. God himself, they
believed, had turned back the quote
insatiable and utterly perverse Arabs.
The Khif's fury fell instead upon the
Christians under his rule. Chronicler
Bar Habraas writes that quote and
because of the disgrace which came upon
the Arabs through their withdrawal from
Constantinople great hatred against the
Christians sprang in the heart of Omar
and he afflicted them severely.
Theophanes is even more blunt. He writes
that quote Omar set about forcing
Christians to become converted. Those
that converted he exempted from tax from
Jiza while those that refused to do so
he killed and so produced many martyrs.
that Constantinople repulsed the
hitherto unstoppable forces of Islam
ranks among the most decisive events in
Western history. The last time a
Christian army had suffered such a
defeat at Yarmmuk in 636, vast Christian
territories were forever lost to Islam.
Had Constantinople fallen, large parts
of Europe, perhaps all of it, might have
gone on to become the northwestern
quadrant of the caliphate before the 8th
century was out. In the words of the
historian John Julius Norwich, quote,
"Had the Sarissens captured
Constantinople in the 7th century rather
than the 15th, all Europe and America
might be Muslim today." Medieval
chronicers grasp the point and treated
August 15th as an ecumenical day, a day
for all of Christendom to rejoice. Even
so, Constantinople, the city once hailed
as the capital of Christianity and its
glory, now bears the name of Istanbul. A
bitter irony as the one-time bull work
of Christryendom went on to become the
seat of modern-day Turkdom. But that is
another story.
[Music]